you've got to create
a lot of different emotion to to to
heighten your sense of awareness and
focus like for me anger was good anger
was good because it was motivating the
more I could create an enemy the more I
want to go and kill those guys now I
knew I wasn't going to kill him
physically
but man if I could just
what did they say you know and
what did they look like and they
disrespect me at all you know and did
that also say something
like those are little little little
things that can get me right in the
emotional frame of mind that when I run
on the field and I said let's go
it was really let's go kick some ass
that's what we were doing